What is the argument for forcing people to get vaccinated?
I mean, the argument for mandatory vaccination is that you get better coverage...
...and that's good for public health.
It's good for everyone's safety and obviously,...
...protects  people who can't get vaccinated or who aren't protected well by vaccines.
Are COVID vaccines mandatory anywhere?
COVID vaccines, by and large, are not mandatory...
...although it will depend where you are in the world...
...and what job you do as well.
And also, it's changing as we speak.
People are formulating new policies on this all the time.
Italy was the first European country to mandate COVID vaccines for healthcare workers.
And I think as we look forward,...
...we'll see lots of healthcare workers being pressured by governments to get vaccines.
And in the US,...
...we were seeing this really interesting pushback against vaccine mandates...
...before they were even implemented.
Many states had passed laws against mandatory vaccinations,...
...states like Florida.
But, with the latest wave of COVID cases,...
...we're seeing that many state governments, many city governments,...
...as well as private institutions are starting to mandate those vaccines.